[Música]
representantes de 20 países aceptaron la
invitación hecha por el gobierno
colombiano para asistir a la llamada
conferencia internacional sobre
Venezuela un encuentro que busca
profundizar sobre el proceso político de
ese país y que tiene como meta destrabar
las conversaciones establecidas entre el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro y la
oposición venezolana el encuentro fue
precedido por el presidente de los
colombianos Gustavo Petro asistieron
también delegaciones de países como por
ejemplo solo por mencionar algunos
Alemania España Francia Italia Noruega
Portugal México Argentina chile y
también el alto representante para
asuntos exteriores y política de
seguridad de la Unión Europea el señor
Joseph
al término del encuentro del canciller
de Colombia Álvaro Leyva dio unas
declaraciones estas fueron sus palabras
recordemos las conclusiones que deja
este encuentro hasta el momento
se identificaron posiciones comunes en
torno a los siguientes temas
uno
la necesidad de Establecer un cronograma
electoral que permita la celebración de
elecciones libres transparentes y con
plenas garantías para todos los actores
venezolanos
que los pasos acordados a satisfacción
de las partes
vayan en paralelo con el levantamiento
de las distintas sanciones
ya lo decíamos la agenda de este
encuentro buscaba tratar esa crisis
política y social de Venezuela un país
del que no asistieron los representantes
del gobierno de Nicolás maduro Pero eso
sí algunos representantes de la
oposición se reunieron previamente
durante el fin de semana anterior con el
presidente colombiano que como
presidente mandatario y anfitrión de
esta reunión Pues fue el encargado de
dar el inicio a la Cumbre y también
estableció algunos puntos clave para dar
la puesta en marcha a este encuentro y
en el caso venezolano creo que tenemos
que andar sobre dos rieles al mismo
tiempo
establecer el cronograma sí
de las elecciones y sus garantías
que el pueblo venezolano pueda decidir
libre y soberanamente que quiere
sin presiones
también el otro riel de levantamiento de
las sanciones Ojalá todo comenzara por
el reingreso de Venezuela al sistema
interamericano de Derechos Humanos
porque al final somos los
latinoamericanos los que tenemos que
decidir si vamos hacia la democracia o
hacia la guerra y la confrontación en
resumen el presidente de los colombianos
aboga por esa necesaria reconstrucción
de la democracia en América Latina por
supuesto en Venezuela y también respalda
uno de los reclamos de la oposición ya
lo mencionaba el un cronograma de
elecciones y garantías democráticas
puede Entonces el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro dar estas garantías Pese a que
esta conferencia cuenta con el respaldo
de Nicolás maduro parece que sus
intenciones van enrutadas a poner fin a
y a que sean levantadas de manera
escalonada las sanciones por parte de
Estados Unidos que pesan sobre el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro y sin haber
comenzado esta conferencia en la ciudad
de Bogotá puso condiciones para
continuar con el diálogo Go con la
oposición en México escuchemos
si alguien de ustedes
quiere aspira
que las negociaciones políticas entre
este sector minoritario la oposición
llamada la plataforma unitaria y el
gobierno bolivariano y chavista de
Venezuela
vuelvan a México
solamente tienen que hacer algo en el
comunicado oficial que ustedes aprueben
pongan la exigencia de que el gobierno
de Estados Unidos de Norteamérica
deposite los tres mil doscientos
millones de dólares secuestrados en las
cuentas bancarias que tenemos en el
exterior y los actualizo el alto
representante de la Unión Europea para
asuntos exteriores y la política de
seguridad Joseph borrell afirmó que el
bloque comunitario está dispuesto a
revisar las sanciones personales que
pesan sobre Nicolás Maduro entre tanto
el líder de la oposición más reconocido
a nivel internacional Juan guaidó pasó
por Bogotá después de haber atravesado
la frontera Colombo venezolana guaidó
buscaba poderse reunir con esas
delegaciones internacionales que
estuvieron presentes en esta conferencia
sin embargo el gobierno colombiano
aclaró que Juan guaidó no había sido
invitado No asistiría a esta conferencia
y además entró al territorio colombiano
de manera irregular porque justamente No
puede salir de su país de manera regular
posteriormente tuvo que tomar un vuelo
comercial hacia la ciudad de Miami en
Estados Unidos esto dijo a su llegada
allí al sur de la Florida
voy hasta ahora 70 horas básicamente o
más
de viaje muy preocupado por mi familia
por mi equipo de trabajo que ya han
visto en las consecuencias de una
dictadura torturados perseguidos
directamente Este paso digamos fugas de
Juan guaidó por Colombia causó mucha
controversia no solamente en ese país
también en Venezuela Y por supuesto en
Estados Unidos este punto lo vamos a
analizar en unos minutos con nuestros
invitados pero entonces qué deja esta
conferencia en torno a la situación
política de Venezuela podrá iniciativa
entonces garantizar esas bases
democráticas ese cronograma para unas
elecciones presidenciales en ese país es
la eliminación de las sanciones contra
el gobierno de Nicolás maduro ese Punto
de partida ese primer paso para poder
Establecer un diálogo o un Punto de
partida entre el gobierno de Venezuela y
la oposición la Cumbre para tratar la
crisis política y social en Venezuela
pues es nuestro tema de debate hoy aquí
en France 24 y para analizar esta Cumbre
y las conclusiones que ha dejado hemos
invitado a Eduardo battistini él es ex
embajador del gobierno interino de
Venezuela ante el gobierno de Colombia y
también es presidente de primer primero
justicia en el exterior se conecta desde
la ciudad de Bogotá en la capital
colombiana y desde Caracas en Venezuela
se conecta Freddy Gutiérrez diputado del
psuv en Venezuela les agradezco a los
dos por estar con nosotros les recuerdo
también a los televidentes que hacen
parte del debate pueden dejar
comentarios preguntas a través de las
redes sociales estamos en todas en
instagram en Facebook y en Twitter
arroba
franz24_s es la cuenta la etiqueta para
que dejen los comentarios numeral el
debate f-24 y a mí me encuentran como
arroba santilogo les recuerdo
rápidamente también que todos los
contenidos del programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast en Spotify
en deezer y en TuneIn
bueno comienzo dándole entonces la
bienvenida a Eduardo en la ciudad de
Bogotá Eduardo Gracias por estar con
nosotros y Punto de partida para la
discusión su opinión sobre esta sobre
esta conferencia sobre este intento
auspiciado por Colombia de comenzar a
unir a la oposición y al gobierno de
Nicolás maduro en algunos puntos en
común o por lo menos dejar algunos
puntos de partida para un diálogo
Buenas noches Santiago Gracias por la
oportunidad y básicamente como lo hemos
dicho en estos últimos días nosotros
confiamos en la buena voluntad del
gobierno de Colombia el gobierno del
presidente de Petro Un gobierno Por
cierto que ha defendido la bandera de
los Derechos Humanos el respeto a los
Derechos Humanos evidentemente nosotros
esperábamos quizás el día de hoy una
declaración conjunta y no un resumen de
conclusiones de los distintos puntos de
vista que se hablaron en la reunión
porque una declaración conjunta marca un
compromiso y una hoja de ruta de estos
20 países para apoyar lo que se viene
dando en México que es la negociación
entre el régimen de maduro y la
plataforma unitaria negociación Por
cierto que hay que aclarar que en dos
veces ha sido detenida por por
responsabilidad del régimen la primera
por ejemplo es cuando el régimen decidió
pararse para no seguir discutiendo los
temas principales de una salida política
para los venezolanos a la crisis que
vive Venezuela para defender a su
corrupto que es el que es Alexa que está
acusado por corrupción cuyo socio Por
cierto Hoy está preso en Venezuela por
una trama de corrupción después que por
mucho tiempo se quiso decir que Alex no
era culpable y lo segundo Santiago es
también decir que el presidente Petro ha
vuelto a poner sobre la mesa algo que
maduro le ha hecho como los toreros de
lole que es el regreso de Venezuela al
sistema interamericano de Derechos
Humanos eso sería un paso fundamental
para la red democratización de Venezuela
para garantizar que los venezolanos
puedan expresarse de manera libre y
democrática para garantizar además los
derechos políticos de quienes hacen vida
en el país Eduardo están dando una lucha
para lograr el cambio democrático pero
por sobre todas las cosas para que
Venezuela pueda empezar a reconocer
lo que significa ese sistema de defensa
de Derechos Humanos Eduardo eso esos son
temas que vamos a estar que vamos a
estar profundizando más adelante en el
programa los dejamos como punto de
inicio para la discusión Quiero conocer
ahora la opinión el punto de vista de
Freddy Gutiérrez en la ciudad de Caracas
Freddy Gracias por estar con nosotros
Bienvenido al programa y su opinión
sobre esta conferencia sobre estas
conclusiones y esta iniciativa que ha
encabezado el gobierno de Colombia
bienvenido buenas noches
Gracias Santiago Gracias por la
oportunidad en este momento me encuentro
aquí en el municipio chacao esto este
estado Miranda que bueno municipio como
tú sabes Santiago que fue epicentro de
la violencia geopolítica causada por
dirigentes de oposición que querían
llevar a nuestro país a una especie de
guerra civil que querían llevar a
nuestro país a una destrucción y
nosotros bueno hemos sido garantes de
seguir el diálogo que tanto ha pedido
nuestro presidente Nicolás Maduro si tú
te pones a analizar Cuántas veces ha
pedido el presidente el diálogo que nos
ganaríamos el premio ahora por otro lado
celebramos primero que se haya realizado
esta Cumbre sobre sobre Venezuela donde
participaron 20 delegaciones
internacionales con el fin de que
primero definitivamente logremos que
acaben las sanciones el bloqueo que son
las medidas coercitivas unilaterales que
de forma responsable algunos políticos
la oposición bueno salieron por el mundo
a pedir más medidas de bloqueo y
sanciones Que impactan negativamente a
toda la familia aquí en este país en
Venezuela Venezuela no hay ninguna
dictadura en Venezuela no hay ningún
régimen yo no entiendo todavía no
entendemos los venezolanos ni siquiera
Los Seguidores de guaidó porque salió de
forma ilegal de Venezuela si desde que
el presidente Petro
en Colombia las relaciones
fronterizas en este caso fueron
retomadas él pudo haber salido por el
puente Simón Bolívar sin ningún problema
Es decir todo obedece a un show
mediático que busca bueno Yo diría que
el último suspiro de Juan guaidó que por
cierto y no fue recibido esta vez en los
Estados Unidos por nadie ni por el
presidente ni por ningún senador por
absolutamente nadie por lo tanto
nosotros celebramos lo que está
ocurriendo en la Cumbre Nosotros sí
estamos de acuerdo que ocurra un un
proceso electoral cosa que estamos
acostumbrados aquí en Venezuela hay
elecciones libres transparentes Freddy
continúo con usted y quiero que nos
remitamos a esas declaraciones del
canciller de Colombia Álvaro Leiva que
dejan en evidencia Pues esa necesidad de
establecer puntos para un proceso
democrático en en Venezuela se habla de
identificación de posiciones en común
pero no hay una hoja de ruta o no hay
puntos de partida y los países
asistentes estos estas 20 delegaciones
acordaron volverse a reunir más adelante
para ver si hay avances en estos tres
puntos que han acordados desde su punto
de vista Freddy hace falta entonces una
hoja de ruta faltó establecer mecanismos
y pasos para poder llegar a esa
democratización que tanto están buscando
y también al levantamiento de esas
sanciones internacionales que tanto está
reclamando el gobierno de Nicolás maduro
Mira fíjate nosotros no podemos
pretender que en un primer momento en
una primera Cumbre se resuelvan los
problemas de Venezuela yo creo que
primero que estamos Venezuela está
construyendo su propio camino que es un
camino soberano un camino democrático un
país donde hemos celebrado más de 23
elecciones yo creo que lo que más hizo
daño fue el llamado gobierno interino
que por cierto bueno saluda aquí al
compañero venezolano Eduardo baristrini
que él sabe muy bien que nunca tuvo una
representación diplomática de un
gobierno interino porque es un gobierno
que nunca existió eso fue un gobierno
comunicacional Un gobierno que lo
respaldó algunos países del mundo pero
que hoy vimos donde su supuesto
presidente interino no fue recibido por
nadie de hecho yo le puedo preguntar al
Señor Dani Eduardo que te queremos mucho
Ojalá y puedas regresar a nuestro país
porque eres venezolano Eduardo
que no está ejerciendo ningún tipo de
cargo diplomático Y en este momento no
se encuentra en la embajada de Venezuela
en Bogotá porque siempre fue una mentira
Siempre fue una falacia quisiéramos
incluso que en el debate nos pudiera
usted decir como embajador en Bogotá Qué
pasó con monómeros Qué pasó
por favor pero no se me olvide el tema
ese no es eso no es lo que le estaba
preguntando lo estoy preguntando por la
hoja de ruta y hay que aclarar que para
ustedes Juan guaidó pues no es un
presidente reconocido pero para más de
50 países alrededor del mundo si recibía
el reconocimiento como el jefe de estado
de un gobierno interino en Venezuela eso
hay que mencionarlo y hay que aclararlo
le pregunto entonces a Eduardo Tratando
de buscar alguna respuesta a a esta
identificación de posiciones comunes que
no plantean una hoja de ruta Entonces se
pregunta uno Cómo lograr esa
democratización Cómo lograr ese
levantamiento de las sanciones como
lograr fortalecer Esa mesa de diálogo
entre las partes
mira lo primero es que en Venezuela no
hay elecciones libres la mejor
demostración es que veinte países del
mundo se reúnen hoy y la y el primer
punto de esas conclusiones es construir
una ruta para que en Venezuela y
elecciones libres entonces bueno
evidentemente nosotros esperábamos
insisto como pueden pasar en una cumbre
de esta un
un acuerdo o una comunicado que tuviese
el consenso de los actores
lamentablemente no lo hubo Pero además
de eso este
sigue insistiendo el régimen de Nicolás
maduro en el tema de las sanciones sigue
insistiendo Nicolás Maduro en el tema de
que no se sienta nuevamente en México
sino liberan a Alex entonces hay unos
condicionamientos que sin duda alguna no
facilitan el proceso de diálogo y sobre
el tema de lo que significa Colombia
brevemente porque me hizo alusión al
compañero y lo quiero aclarar en un
minuto dos cosas yo fui embajador de
gobierno interino cuando el gobierno
interino era reconocido en solamente un
año en ese año te comento hermano que se
apostillaron setenta mil documentos
universitarios donde hoy más de 25.000
venezolanos han podido convalidar su
profesión en Colombia y te lo debo
además como un dato porque por ejemplo
desde hace ocho meses se reactivó la
embajada del régimen de maduro como el
restablecimiento de las relaciones
diplomáticas y Le puedes preguntar a
cualquier venezolano en las calles de
Colombia Si todavía recibió su pasaporte
si le han dado una cédula identidad se
ha podido apostillar un documento se ha
podido hacer algún trámite y no lo ha
podido hacer entre otras cosas porque la
embajada continúa cerrada porque no le
da servicios a los venezolanos Eduardo
Aquí hay un punto importante también
para analizar y tal vez a falta de esa
hoja de ruta que simplemente y una falta
también de una declaración conjunta es
que no han asistido a este encuentro ni
representantes del gobierno de Nicolás
maduro ni representantes de la oposición
yo lo mencionaba en la introducción que
algunos delegados de la oposición se
reunieron el fin de semana previo a este
encuentro con el presidente
Gustavo Petro justamente para mirar
algunos puntos y requerimientos Como por
ejemplo la libertad de los presos
políticos y el cese de las violaciones
de los Derechos Humanos en Venezuela
entre otros puntos cree usted que faltó
la presencia de estos dos actores
importantes en en esta conferencia o
simplemente con este punto de vista
general de la comunidad internacional
tomándolo como Punto de partida
simplemente que son 20 países bastaba
para encontrar ese punto de acuerdo
Mira yo creo que no estuvo planteado
desde el principio de la Cumbre que
asistiera ni el régimen de maduro ni la
plataforma unitaria al día de hoy 25 lo
que sí se realizó previamente como tú lo
recordarás el canciller Álvaro Leiva o
joven es un viajó a Venezuela el domingo
pasado el domingo antepasado para
reunirse con Nicolás maduro y la
plataforma unitaria se reunió con el
presidente Gustavo Petro el pasado fin
de semana y creo que ese fue el espacio
para que ambas partes pudiesen expresar
Cuáles eran sus líneas rojas y cuáles
eran sus peticiones para ser planteados
en la mesa pero también hay que decir
algo que también es bastante cierto los
países que participaron hoy en esta
Cumbre tienen bastante Clara la realidad
y las aspiraciones de ambos sectores en
este proceso yo creo que aquí lo único
que falta es que haya la voluntad para
volver a México para que México se pueda
dar entonces la discusión de la salida
de la ruta política que es una de las
cosas que se firmó en el memoraron
emprendimiento y yo sí creo y te lo digo
con mucha sinceridad que hoy faltó para
mí contundencia por parte de Quienes
participaron en la Cumbre para que esa
hoja de ruta se pudiese ya con fecha
específica volver a sentar en México
Freddy retomo algunas de las palabras
que dice Eduardo voluntad por parte del
gobierno de Nicolás maduro hay voluntad
por parte de maduro para restablecer
esta mesa de diálogo hay voluntad para
hacer un acercamiento con la oposición
en México y para sentar las bases de un
proceso electoral limpio por lo menos a
los ojos de la comunidad internacional
porque ya usted nos ha explicado que a
los ojos de el gobierno de Nicolás
maduro y de las autoridades venezolanas
pues han sido procesos
transparentes desde el punto de vista de
ustedes así sean cuestionados por la
comunidad internacional
lo que pasa Santiago Es que la comunidad
internacional Incluso se ha dado cuenta
que todo este cuento del interinato el
gobierno de interinato que nunca existió
era solo algo comunicacional tenía un
apoyo de un gobierno que entendió que se
dio bueno que que cometió un gran error
que fue el gobierno del presidente
Donald Trump por eso es que nosotros
vemos como Juan guaidó Incluso el día de
hoy no lo recibe absolutamente nadie en
los Estados Unidos incluso bueno hemos
visto como ese gobierno interinato acabó
fue la misma oposición
venezolana fueron sus mismos compañeros
de lucha que pidieron que cesara el
gobierno interinato porque sabe muy bien
que le trajo mucho daño
el país ahora fíjate algo las elecciones
en Venezuela siempre ha sido de forma
transparente Yo invito incluso a todos
los medios de comunicación lo invito a
usted Santiago que pueda visitar el país
cuando haya cualquier proceso electoral
el detalle está que la oposición
difícilmente reconoce cuando pierden las
elecciones pero aquí hay un proceso
dentro de cada centro electoral el cual
tiene testigos de mesa tiene testigos de
toda la oposición que le Reporta a otros
testigos en un estado de aquí de nuestro
país y luego reportan a una sola
situación en todo el Consejo Nacional
electoral pero adicionalmente a estos
hacen las auditorías por eso es que
nosotros hemos reconocido incluso cuando
por ejemplo perdimos la asamblea
nacional no tenemos la culpa de que
cuando la oposición llega o ocupa algún
carro en este caso la asamblea nacional
no hacen o no ejercen el poder que el
pueblo le ha dado sino que piensan es en
tratar de desmontar una presidenta de la
República cuando se olvidan de hacerle
el bien al país por lo tanto yo veo muy
negativo que no reconozcan los procesos
electorales internos de nuestro país Yo
le agradezco esta explicación que nos
hace el proceso electoral de Venezuela
lo conozco muy bien Estuve cubriendo las
presidenciales del 2018 allí en la
ciudad de Caracas Pero no evada mi
pregunta le estoy preguntando por la
voluntad del presidente Nicolás Maduro
quiere el presidente maduro sentarse a
negociar con la oposición en México sí o
no
la pregunta estoy diciendo porque usted
está acelerando usted Está celebrando
Que aquí hay procesos que no son
transparentes cuando usted mismo Está
viendo está diciendo que ha estado en
los procesos electorales en nuestro país
si usted como periodista reconoce que
vio algo inusual Ojalá y lo pueda decir
aquí públicamente estoy seguro que no ha
habido nadie inusual ahora para que
usted no diga que hago la pregunta le
puedo decir el presidente Nicolás Maduro
todos los venezolanos y venezolanas y
más lo que estamos dentro de la
Revolución bolivariana apostamos al
diálogo pero nosotros queremos que nos
levantemos las sanciones que nos
levanten el bloqueo que devuelvan los
tres mil doscientos millones de dólares
que de forma injusta nos quitaron a los
venezolanos que nos devuelvan el oro
Pero ha sido el presidente Nicolás
Maduro el mismo que ha llamado al
diálogo es el presidente Nicolás Maduro
que le ha dicho a su delegaciones que
acudan a México que acudan y que se
reúnan por eso es que nosotros estamos
viendo como presidente Petro está
visitando Venezuela como nuestras
delegaciones están visitando Colombia y
cómo se está dando una Cumbre sobre
Venezuela en Bogotá con la participación
de más de 20 países yo creo que no
debemos acelerarnos a lo que van a ser
las próximas fases de este nuevo proceso
de diálogo que fue principalmente
impulsado por el reino de Noruega en
México sí Freddy lo que no entiende uno
es que usted habla que el presidente
maduro es el que fomenta este diálogo
cuando él mismo está poniendo
condiciones para poder instaurar el
diálogo y no ofrece una puerta de
diálogo para solucionar esos puntos que
no tienen en común no vamos a analizar
más adelante dejémoslo ahí sobre la mesa
Freddy paso a darle la palabra a Eduardo
en la ciudad de Bogotá Cómo ve usted
entonces hay voluntad o no hay voluntad
de Miraflores para esta negociación hay
diferentes sectores de la oposición que
dicen que simplemente Nicolás Maduro
Está tratando de ganar un poco más de
tiempo
dilatando un poco las cosas incluso
María Corina Machado dice que le
preocupa que Nicolás Maduro convierta
esta cumbre en Bogotá en un evento para
truncar justamente las elecciones
primarias de la oposición
Mira voluntad creo que quedó demostrado
en distintos procesos no solamente en
este de México que es muy poca la
voluntad que tiene maduro en este
sentido y además coloca excusas que a
veces para los que nos ven afuera es
importante que conozcan se habla por
ejemplo de los tres mil doscientos
millones que según le robaron al pueblo
de Venezuela tres mil millones por
ejemplo se robó solamente joselyn
Ramírez en la trama de corrupción de
pedevesa que además no eran tres mil
millones que venían del cielo eran tres
mil millones que salieron de la venta
petrolera y que evadiendo las sanciones
lo convirtieron en criptomonedas Para
robarselo eso hay que decírselo a los
venezolanos sobre el tema del Oro de
Inglaterra lo que está en Inglaterra que
está protegido y no ha sido gastado es
el siete por ciento de las reservas del
Oro venezolano lo que no se dice Es que
desde el año 2013 desde 2012 perdón el
propio Hugo Chávez empezó a llevarse el
oro a Venezuela y va a llover A cuánto
están las reservas del oro en Venezuela
Y cuánto dilapirado el régimen de maduro
de esas reservas de oro aquí el tema
central y creo que hay lo que ha dicho
el presidente Gustavo Petro hace ocho
meses se le pidió el presidente Gustavo
Petro en la primera visita de Venezuela
el retorno al sistema interamericano de
Derechos Humanos a Venezuela y todavía
no hay respuesta sobre eso y eso es un
tema de defensa de los derechos humanos
y un régimen que se hace Llamar
socialista humanista le elude a ese tema
y yo insisto no hay voluntad cuando por
ejemplo hoy se le siguen secuestrando
las tarjetas de los partidos políticos a
sus verdaderos líderes a través de un
tres de un tribunal supremo de Justicia
que está al Servicio del poder yo le
preguntaría hoy a los que nos ven por
ejemplo en Colombia Qué pasaría si la
Corte Suprema de Justicia le diría
mañana al presidente Petro que él ya no
es el dueño de la tarjeta del pacto
histórico sino que es otra persona y es
otra persona Apuesta por el tribunal el
que decide quién se postule quien no en
Venezuela no hay elecciones libres entre
otras cosas lo que lo dijo la comisión
de la Unión Europea que por cierto tenía
13 años que no le permitían entrar a
Venezuela y se lo permitieron el 21 de
noviembre y ha hecho una serie de
recomendaciones que han sido
desestimadas y no ha sido ninguna tomada
en cuenta por el poder electoral
entonces Y tú que has estado en
Venezuela Santiago
cubriendo elecciones sabes que el tema
de los Testigos es relativo porque una
cosa es tener testigos en museo
electoral y que lleve un grupo de
colectivos armados y a punta de pistola
lo saques del centro electoral o que el
plan República Lamentablemente se preste
muchas veces para que no haya un
equilibrio en las mesas electorales En
todo caso nosotros aspiramos que este
encuentro en Colombia permita y convive
a el régimen de madura que se vuelva a
sentar en México Porque la única excusa
que tenía que tiene que tener tanto la
plataforma como el régimen de maduro es
llegar a un acuerdo para que en
Venezuela haya elecciones libres y para
que de alguna u otra forma todo
relajamiento de sanciones que por cierto
hay sanciones que son individuales se
puedan ir levantando Y por supuesto las
sanciones que lamentablemente porque eso
y así lo tengo que reconocer hay que han
afectado No han sido el origen de la
crisis pero han han empeorado quizás un
poco la situación en los últimos dos
años yo complemento lo que dice Eduardo
son 23 las recomendaciones que hizo la
misión electoral de la Unión Europea en
esas elecciones del 2018
recomendaciones que fueron presentadas
en el año 2021 y entre esas 23 destacó
dos la creación de un consejo electoral
independiente y que por ejemplo la
contraloría no pudiera sancionar a
candidatos a los diferentes cargos a los
que se están postulando a través de
estos procesos electorales para evitar
justamente que este organismo pueda
hacer un cerco a por ejemplo a los
movimientos opositores solo por
mencionar algunos Y darles algunas de
las recomendaciones que hacía la Unión
Europea regreso con Freddy Freddy Aquí
hay un punto importante y es esa
necesidad de Venezuela de regresar al
escenario internacional si no fuera un
país relevante para la región de América
Latina no estarían 20 delegaciones de 20
países sentados en Bogotá negociando
como marcaron una hoja de ruta para que
Venezuela tenga una salida a la
situación política y social que está
presentando
qué tan apremiante es para Venezuela
regresar al escenario internacional qué
tan apremiante es para ustedes para el
movimiento chavista y para el gobierno
de Nicolás maduro Volver al escenario
internacional
fíjate nosotros primero que ya estamos
en el en la comunidad internacional yo
creo que hay un reconocimiento de la
situación que está ocurriendo aquí en
Venezuela creo que por esto parte esta
iniciativa de realizar esta Cumbre sobre
Venezuela en Bogotá donde participaron
esta veinte delegaciones pero no podemos
olvidar también con todas las alianzas
que tiene nuestra República con varios
países por ejemplo
de la unasur del Alba de mecanismos
internacionales o gigantes como la
República Popular de China Rusia Cuba
nosotros tenemos apoyo internacional y
estoy seguro que así como que ese
reconocimiento que no se le ha dado más
a este famoso gobierno interino donde ya
países han reconocido sus errores va a
Seguir generando una especie de efecto
de dominó y yo creo que hoy Bueno fue la
gota que derramó el vaso donde vimos que
ya guaidó no tiene ningún tipo de apoyo
donde ya la oposición está otra causa se
hablaba de que en Venezuela no hay
elecciones libres y transparentes Pero
cómo Entonces puede definir el hermano
Eduardo baristrini como un partido nuevo
democrático por ejemplo como fuerza
vecinal hoy tiene más de siete alcaldías
tiene una gobernación Incluso el
chavismo en Venezuela perdimos un estado
emblemático como es barinas estado
emblemático Que es una de las Revolución
bolivariana lo perdimos con el mismo cne
que le dio la credencial Por ejemplo a
mi contenedor que fue el alcalde Gustavo
Duque candidato a la alcaldía de sacado
y yo perdí las elecciones y reconocí el
triunfo del alcalde Duque Entonces yo
creo que ahora también hay factores de
oposición hablando de de la no
transparencia del Consejo Nacional
electoral pero si quieren ir a primaria
como lo es María Corina Machado como lo
es Enrique capriles que ha participado
varias veces como candidato presidencial
que fue varias veces gobernador de
Miranda y una oposición que hoy sí está
desplegada sin todos los municipios en
todos los estados del país porque
quieren ganar una Primaria para luego ir
a una elección presidencial Entonces
cuando tú analizas el discurso de la
oposición que está hoy dentro del país y
el discurso que hoy está de oposición
que está fuera del país como el
embajador de un gobierno que nunca
existió Eduardo tú te das cuenta que son
personas que no tienen definitivamente
el pie sobre la Tierra que perdieron
definitivamente la noción del tiempo la
noción de cómo se está llevando la
política en Venezuela y que por otro
lado nosotros no tenemos la culpa de la
diferencias internas que tengan los
partidos de oposición
porque es la misma posición la que está
haciendo todo bueno las acciones legales
para que empiecen otra a la actuación
legal partido ya eso es culpa de ellos
nosotros nos agregamos Eso sí Perdón que
lo que te interrumpa pero debo agilizar
porque me queda poco tiempo para
terminar el análisis y dentro de ese
análisis Le quiero preguntar sobre la
gestión que está haciendo el presidente
colombiano Gustavo Petro impulsar esta
conferencia convocar a estos
representantes de 20 países el esfuerzo
también de la cancillería colombiana y
esas reuniones que han sostenido maduro
y Petro todo esto con Ánimo de ayudarle
a Venezuela volver a a integrarse y a
ser parte por lo menos de del escenario
internacional y que les sean por lo
menos escuchado sus reclamos desde
Miraflores su opinión
Bueno mi opinión con respecto a eso que
esta iniciativa es Fabulosa yo debo de
recordar cuando aquí nuestro
expresidente comandante Hugo Rafael
Chávez frías también fue mediador ante
ese proceso de diálogo en lo que era
bueno esa guerra del narcotráfico en
Colombia donde también Venezuela dio su
grano de arena para alcanzar la paz que
bueno después Vimos una parte que se
derrumbó con los gobiernos por ejemplo
de Iván Duque y Manuel Santos Entonces
yo creo que es recíproco Recuerda que
nuestras naciones tienen el mismo sueño
que es el sueño bolivariano Bolívar como
libertador de ambas naciones nos llama
estar Unidos los gobiernos anteriores de
Colombia quería que nosotros fuéramos a
una confrontación incluso Armada entre
pueblos hermanos Es por eso que nosotros
vemos un presidente como presidente
Gustavo Petro un presidente como Nicolás
Maduro bueno dialogando para buscar la
solución de todos los venezolanos nunca
nosotros a un Juan guaidó Llamando a la
paz Llamando a la democracia lo vimos
Llamando a la violencia Llamando
al bloqueo a las sanciones cosas que yo
creo que no van a volver a pasar en este
país pues en este momento tienen
sanciones internacionales por parte de
la Unión Europea y por parte de Estados
Unidos Eduardo lo mencionaba yo como
parte de la actualización que el alto
representante de la Unión Europea yo
borreel dijo que el bloque comunitario
está dispuesto a estudiar esas sanciones
que pesan sobre el gobierno de Venezuela
como analiza usted este punto
mira como te lo dije al principio hay
que dividir organizaciones personales
contra quienes están acusados de
corrupción lavado de dinero narcotráfico
Y fíjate que esas esas sanciones
personales son tan ciertas que también
el aissami tenía una sanción por los
Estados Unidos por estar involucrado en
una red de narcotráfico corrupción y fue
el mismo régimen de maduro quien está ha
estado
lo capturó lo tiene no sabe dónde lo
tienen pero supongamos que lo tiene
detenido y donde ha quitado o ha
detenido casi toda esa Red porque el
compañero hablaba de que la oposición no
se pone de acuerdo no nosotros tenemos
debates y discusiones los que tienen una
pugna interna son ellos que se andan
metiendo presos unos con otros en el
caso de barinas bueno en barinas ustedes
perdieron la elección la desconocieron
inhabilitaron a cuatro candidatos y el
pueblo valía les dio una lección de que
por más poder que quieren imponer y por
más que quieran imponer no es factible Y
por último el tema de la paz total en
Colombia yo valoro mucho lo que el
presidente Pedro está haciendo por
lograr una salida en Venezuela pero una
de las grandes cosas que es fundamental
para que la paz total en Colombia pueda
funcionar es que haya democracia en
Venezuela Porque esa Paz Total que se
quebrantó en Colombia entre otras cosas
pasa porque el eln hoy tiene presencia
en más de dos estados del país y es
dueño con anuencia de las fuerzas
armadas y con el régimen de Nicolás
maduro del negocio más perverso que hay
en Venezuela que es el arco minero donde
se ha generado el ecocidio más grande de
la región y donde por ejemplo hoy esa
fuerza del lln asesinado a 30 y ante eso
el régimen calle me queda un minuto para
finalizar el programa ya conocemos la
posición que tiene Eduardo frente a Juan
guaidó y a su llegada Perdón que tiene
Freddy frente a esta llegada de Juan
guaidó a Estados Unidos Eduardo usted
cómo ve el personaje de Juan guaidó que
fue presidente interino de Venezuela
reconocido por 50 países que ahora pues
llega a Estados Unidos
y no hay un futuro definido para él
Mira Juan guaidó le ha tocado salir del
país como le han tocado a muchos líderes
de la oposición por la persecución
política no es cierto que Juan guaidó
podía pasar la frontera y llegar
Alzheimer en Venezuela que le sellara su
pasaporte y entrara a Colombia y que le
enseñaran su pasaporte recordemos que
Juan guaidó por parte del tribunal de la
dictadura tiene prohibición de salida
del país como muchísimos otros
dirigentes pero en todo caso ya le
corresponderá a él definir y que va a
ser en su futuro y cuál va a ser cuál va
a seguir su lucha pero en todo caso lo
que sí te puedo reafirmar es que en
Venezuela sigue muchos líderes de la
oposición que están dando una dura lucha
que a nosotros desde afuera lo que nos
toca es apoyarlo y también ser parte de
la voz de la de lo que ellos no les
ponen de lo que ellos no pueden decir
por la persecución dentro del país
Eduardo en la ciudad de Bogotá y a
Freddy en la ciudad de Caracas les
agradezco mucho por haber estado con
nosotros en el debate se nos acaba el
tiempo debo dar paso al siguiente bloque
de noticias gracias por haber estado con
nosotros y haber hecho este análisis
para la audiencia de France 24 en
América Latina ustedes también gracias
por la sintonía la producción del
programa estuvo a cargo de Andrés doncel
y la producción de invitados estuvo a
cargo de Tania Herrera Pueden seguir
dejando sus comentarios y preguntas a
través de las redes sociales sigan con
nosotros
[Música]